um I'm really happy to be here and I
really like to it Ian's side about like
starting skiff talks cuz one of the
first conferences I went to was PI data
in Boston like three years ago and I
went on my birthday like I have like I
said birthday present to myself I guess
I don't know it was on my birthday and I
was like so excited and I was like other
people are excited to python and like
data step to this is the best and like I
had a good time and I gave a lightning
talk and now I give orthotic said it's
the best so I'm stoked so um we're going
to talk about machine learning which is
one of my favorite things um I saw this
talk in the last session where the
speaker was talking about how he trained
a computer to UM to play space invaders
and to win right and he trained the
computer to play Duman to win and I was
so impressed because like this is like
the promise of machine learning right is
that like you're like one person any
type like your laptop and like some AWS
instances and you pee like eight dollars
and then you can like train a computer
to these amazing things I managed really
true and I kind of love machine learning
but it's also kind of weird and does
some dumb stuff I'm so we're gonna talk
about like how we love it and also how
it's kind of weird and dumb so um about
me um I actually spent the last two
years doing machine learning for real
like they paid me and stuff and I worked
on machine learning stop that credit
card fraud um so I won't talk for like
three seconds about what machine
learning is just to make sure that like
we all know so I tried to come up with
like the simplest possible problem and I
was like well when I see someone's a
name I can like guests like what country
they are there from right so I can be
like Oh John is probably like American
like Johannes this probably maybe German
or something because like this is lots
of people in Germany um until the way it
works is like you would imagine like
your perfect data set and you just take
like every person in the world and be
like well you have every version of the
world named Julia I'm like what country
do they live it right um and then you
take all of your data and then you make
into a model and you can imagine just
like dropping all of the least common
countries to be like julia is like
definitely American which would be wrong
time Canadian okay
but like um you'd be right like most of
the time I'm so machine learning is just
like you take a bunch of data and then
you make a model and usually the model
is like a lot simpler than your data
right like this model is like less takes
up less space on the screen okay cool um
and yeah so your models basically just
your data ok now that we talked about
like really basic stuff we're gonna do
like weird stuff and talk about
something fun which is neural networks
um who watched the alpha go game and was
like oh my god who's gonna win oh my god
me too i was like surprisingly into it i
didn't really expect it i was like oh
this is gonna be boring and then I was
like but who's gonna win today and then
it kept on going for five days and I was
so into it anyway um so like I watched
this game right um and I was like really
confused about what's going on with
neural networks I don't want to know a
little bit more about them and what was
happening and in particular there's this
feature on google photos which had been
like mystifying to me and upsetting to
me for a long time where you search for
like beaches and then it shows you
pictures of like you at the beach like
that's me at the beach like Puerto Rico
and it was really fun and I'm with my
friends you can see anyway it's just
like so great a search like cars and
it's like oh there's cars but there's
also like Turkish men fishing which is
different from cars it's like like it's
like kind of good but also kind of weird
and I used to a fire hydrant then it's
like all over it like it showed me like
only fire hydrants um this is a vital
trip to Toronto and like I was like
really surprised at the fire hydrants
were yellow I don't know I took a lot of
picture as the fire hydrants um and then
I central or baby and it just showed me
pictures of me which I didn't really
understand like they were like only two
babies and almost zero uh yeah it was
just like all of me so like that's kind
of weird so I want to know what's going
on unlike something about Henry all
networks work um so uh I went to a bar
one day and someone gave me this paper
I'll give me three papers and this was
one of them because i only read papers
if someone like gives them to me in
person within paper um so it was called
explaining and harnessing adversarial
examples and i read it and i was like oh
man i think i understand something about
neural networks now I'm
I want to like tell people about it um
and in particular one thing that this
paper reminded me of um was that no one
that works or not in fact like magic um
they're just like math right um like
they're you write down some equations
and like you have your computer
calculate some things and like maybe it
works maybe it doesn't um and I
remembered that I have a math degree
which is like very helpful and I was
like oh maybe I can like understand how
this works because I actually do know
math why not um when I just say that I
basically like didn't know anything
about neural networks going into this
I'm even though machine learning is my
job and but I kind of wanted to know cuz
I like felt bad that I didn't know
anything about them so I read this paper
um and the paper was like pretend we
have like a neural network as I can
classify images I'm much like the Google
focused thing that like I don't
understand why it thanks I'm a baby um
and it can classify like pandas so and
and also other things I'm so it says you
can take a picture of panda and they
don't know a little bit like that's a
panda and then you can change it a
little bit in perceptively so that the
neural network thinks with panda is a
vulture so I was like oh that's like
kind of surprising and weird and cool
right and like I felt like if I
understood how this happened um then I
could understand your networks like a
little bit better like five percent
better right um so it was like a four
page paper I had my laptop here and I
want to know like can I like implement
the stuff in the paper on my laptop um
the answer turns out to be yes which was
good because i emailed someone I was
like I'm gonna write an article where I
implement stuff in this paper and then I
was like oh God can actually do it and
it was like kind of scary um so the code
for all this is all in like a Jupiter
notebook which is um like on my github
because it turns out that it's not that
hard um even they took me like four days
but I didn't know anything so four days
isn't bad okay so what's a neural
network um I find it like easy to get
into the weeds of like Oh what is it
truly in its sole and you're like okay
it's a fun
right um it's a function which takes an
images of dogs and it's like that's a
dog right this one in particular and in
fact it doesn't just say it's a dog you
taking an image of a dog and then it's
like okay it's maybe a dog or a
different dog or a different dog or a
different dog or different dog and then
at the end it's like or maybe a tennis
ball and it keeps going it's like no but
i think is a dog so say so for like
every different label in the data set
you have like the probability that this
image is that label right so there's
some lower probability that this is like
a offense or like whatever or sword um
but tennis balls the only one that made
it up to the top 15 um and the shape of
the input data um is of course not
actually an image but like a bunch of
like RGB pairs right um so these are the
reds and greens and blues for a cat I
believe it um okay so then the next
thing I did after I read this paper was
I spent like 10 hours setting up like
neural network software on my computer
and I was like oh what's happening but i
eventually figured it out and it wasn't
too bad i use a software called cafe
Kaffee IDK um and then so the paper um i
think people often talk about training
neural networks I don't actually know
how to do that um but I can I know how
to download one right so the neural
network was talking the paper was
talking about this network called Google
net which one some competition in like
twenty fourteen and I was like that's
pretty legit can i download it and so I
could download it so i clicked download
and it was like 50 megabytes and then I
had it on my computer which was my goal
um and then I wanted to predict stuff
with it right and see if I could
actually get it to work um and so I was
like what the sword and it was like I
think that's a paper knife and I was
like okay why not and then it told me
that this cat was a cat and it told me
that this garbage can was a garbage can
and I was really happy and then told me
at this Queen was like a shower cap
and like so it turns out the video
network does not impact know about
people that's not like a concept it's
aware of which is it may be a good
lesson about machine learning but anyway
um so I made all these like fun
predictions and I'd like tweeted about
it I'd be like ha ha ha Twitter it's a
shower cap very funny um and then we
need to get down to business of like
implementing the paper right um so we
needed to trick the neural network um
there's an intervening intervening step
here where I was like really confused
and I like tweeted about stuff and I was
like what's going on not like people
explained it to me and then it was ok so
when you talk about some math for a
second so I have this really great graph
where you have some images you have some
space of images and for every image you
have the amount that that image is like
a panda right according to the neural
network so the math that we're doing is
we have our image is somewhere up high
right our panda is very much like a
panda and what we want to do is we want
to make it less like a panda um so this
is like pretty simple like conceptually
and then all we have to do is figure out
like how do we get that arrow right like
how do I figure out which direction to
go and because we don't want to
accidentally go up and there's like a
bajillion dimensions so it's kind of
hard to find the right direction um it
turns out that it's actually not hard to
find the right direction um because the
way you find the direction to change
bogdan's you take the derivative right
which is what we learn in calculus um
which is the word that like math degree
helped so you take the derivative and
turns out that taking the derivative a
neural network is actually really easy
it's like a really basic supported
operation and the way you do it is by
this algorithm called back propagation
I'm but really what you do is you just
like run the derivative function and you
do it so super easy um so what we did as
I started out I want to start it was
something like really simple so I
started out with a blank screen and I
was like what's a blank screen and it
was like well I think that's velvet or a
shower curtain or a paper towel
I was like okay hello whatever neural
network so I wanted to make it more like
paper towel um so I looked at how much
was like paper towel right and took the
derivative in the direction of like a
more paper towel and it was like that's
that's like what I think like the
essence of paper towel is right now okay
so before we were at like four percent
paper towel and then when we add it when
we add this like vector um we get up to
fourteen percent hero towel which is
like cool but not one hundred percent so
um the next thing I tried was I was like
well if instead of taking one big step I
take a lot of like little tiny steps
maybe it'll work better so I tried that
and it totally did work better um the
blue line is like how much is like a
paper towel and it goes like all the way
up to like a hundred percent when it
take a lot of like little steps um and
we end up with a paper towel it's
probability like ninety-nine point nine
percent obviously and if you blow up
this image you can actually see they're
all these like little weird swirly
things just kind of cool that made me
like feel better but what was going on I
was like oh it thinks that the swirlies
are like a fatality or something I don't
know um who knows what's actually
happening um so we can do a little bit
more of this too so I took a garbage can
and if Jay like the derivative of the
neural network around the garbage can
you get like a little garbage can shape
but it's really cute and I was really
happy um um oh yeah I also turn to
kitten into a bath towel so it turns out
if you did make a kid unless like a
kitten um it quickly turns into a
bathtub which is like kind of adorable
in a lot of ways um and then i
subtracted the kid from the bath towel
kitten so like like and then i got this
um and you can kind of maybe see okay so
i asked someone else if I could see that
those like in the right corner there
were ears and now I'm like maybe I made
that up so I don't know but I felt like
there are ears in this image when I
looked at it the first time maybe you
don't
um so but I promised you the path from a
panda to a vulture so i'm going to show
you the graph i did 100 steps and in
order to become a vulture if you're a
panda apparently you need to first
become like a given and a Madagascar cat
and an ostrich and all kinds of weird
other stuff and i actually asked someone
who works at Google about this um and he
was like oh yeah totally there's like
this like panda ostrich spaceship images
and I was like what are you talking
about like how is this an obvious back
to you I don't understand uh but but I
thought it was cool um because when I
work with data sets I might get to like
know those datasets really well and I
got to know like weird facts about those
datasets really well I'm so I thought it
was cool that like he always like new
this set of like input images to like
this um machine learning like
competition really well and he knew that
like pandas I think this might be just
cause they're both black I don't know I
have questions um um so yeah this was
like the result then I was really happy
and I got it to work on my computer
which is what I wanted um I wanted to
show you just like how much coat this
was just like I think not a lot that was
like basically all the codes it's like
cut off on the side but doesn't matter
because you can't read it anyway um and
the kind of like core of the code is lit
I was like hey I want to like a trick
this image into being this like desired
output and so I just like do this loop
and then I like take the derivative and
unlike add like a small Delta and then
like I keep on doing that and then at
the end I'm done um so it was like
surprisingly simple and like I just
tried stuff that I thought would work
according to the paper the paper said it
would work and then did work on the
stuff they can kind of do yourself I've
worked like a particle about it which
you can go read and there's like a
docker image and all the code is there
but one thing that I thought was cool
about this and maybe like important is
that if you can trick a neural network
maybe you can like start to understand
it right and maybe you don't understand
everything about it because like I don't
know it's like a whole research domain
right and if you understood everything
about it maybe someone to pay you like a
bajillion dollars um but we can start to
understand like something and so we know
that machine learning is really cool um
but the other info
anything to think of that is like
machine learning is also kind of
important right so you can do this like
really still pull stuff on your computer
but then sometimes the cool stuff that
used on your computer gets used to like
affect like actual decisions and stuff
right like that's why like I got paid to
do machine learning so you have things
like photo classification which are
maybe not that big of a deal um I maybe
doesn't really matter if a google photos
thinks that I'm baby um evident is like
spam filtering which affects what email
you get which is maybe more important
and then people often get really excited
about things I like oh maybe if we can
use machine learning to proof like loan
applications splick to figure out like
if you should get money trying your
business and like oh god like machine
learning is ridiculous I don't want to
do that I'm afraid um so I just wanted
to like talk to her a few reasons to be
kind of skeptical of machine learning
even though like I love it so much um
and so it like one thing is like and a
lot of these I think things that I think
are really like evidence like machine
learning practitioners um so like it's
only as good as the data you put into it
all right like we talked about this like
julia is canadian data and if you like
forget about like China then like you're
not going to be able to classify any
Chinese people and but this can happen
in like less obvious ways right so
sometimes I would be like looking at um
like people would ask me why we didn't
catch some fraud and they're like well
like what about this thing that happened
to hear ago and I might be like oh are
Alec Rossum doesn't know about stuff
that happened a year ago so it couldn't
look at that right um and it's released
like two like accidentally like Levi
data which is actually really important
um and then the machines can't learn
from it because it's not there who
writes programs who r its programs with
bugs me too um I think one thing that I
told someone and they're like oh that's
obvious but I didn't realize is that
machine learning programs also just have
bugs in them that are dumb so for
example like you can imagine um you
could use like a country database to
identify IP addresses and that country
database could just get out of date and
then you're like wrong about
country that i feei just comes from and
then maybe you make a bad decision based
on that or maybe you just have a bug in
your code right um and so like you kind
of like this like pure magical
mathematical world of beauty and then
you have like your actual program which
is like quite different and like may not
actually work um this is really good
paper about like the fact that machine
learning programs have bugs and that
it's like quite hard to design um really
robust like large scale and machine
learning systems called machine learning
the high-interest credit card card a
technical debt by Google um and I really
love it and I read it and I was like
it's me it's my life so if you're
interested in this topic of like how to
make machine learning systems that um
like process like tons of events and
need to like work well at scale this is
a really good paper it's like very
accessible written it's like six to ten
pages or something um I really love it
um another thing that can happen is you
for Australia model at people which was
this like thing here right um I think
this is like surprisingly normal that
like you like decided to model something
and you had some view of the world when
you made your decisions and then later
on you were like oh that makes no sense
because I forgot like this like class
altogether right um and then the Machine
looks like that's what you told me to do
and you're like oh yeah well okay um and
then sometimes it just like doesn't work
right um so this is like another thing
that google photos thinks is a baby
which is a Donald Trump pinata uh-huh I
don't know um and what I so I did San
Francisco like months ago actually like
eight months ago um it wasn't as intense
then um but um yeah so some and like one
thing that I liked it like remind people
of is if you have a machine learning
algorithm which is right like eighty
percent at the time I think that's
considered like really good putting this
will be wrong like twenty percent of the
time right um and oh I won't say
something up bugs yeah um one thing I
want to say about bugs is sometimes
people would like will tell me that my
machine learning isn't working
and I'll be like oh it's probably doing
some like cool smart machine learning
thing right and then like I'll go look
and I'll be like oh haha like it wasn't
doing a cool smart machine learning
thing and that happens like more often
than i would like to like admit even
though apparently i'm telling all of you
um and then the last thing about machine
learning is it can have sort of like
weird unexpected consequences I think
these weird i'm facing consequences i
could often get like a lot of press so
there's this news a while ago about
target and how they wrote some like
analytics to figure out if someone might
be pregnant and then they could send out
send them like cool coupons um I'm like
for like maternity clothing and they
wrote the stuff and it totally worked
and then people got this mail and then
some would be like hey you're pregnant
and the personal Philly oh god you
weren't supposed to know that um and
this is like a super important topic
which I'm not really going to talk about
a lot but this is a really good talk
about this called consequences of an
insightful algorithm by Karina zona
where she just has like a lot of
different interest in cases um which are
fun to think of it or not fun terrifying
interesting to think of it um so I think
like we all work with data and we're all
kind of like skeptical and we know to
ask questions let me know that like data
science is like often like kind of like
things everything goes wrong all the
time um I watch a lot of talk is the
kind of like stuff here and there like
do the right thing fix your models make
them work and I'm like oh how the help
um so as you want to look like a little
bit of a model debugging and like how to
make stuff that works because I think
it's really fun except that works so one
thing that I do sometimes is all like
magically guess right and a little bit
like what's wrong and I'll be like I
know with my brain because I'm amazing
um this works only occasionally Oh the
second thing um this is a really obvious
thing to do which is like look at the
model um so this is really easy if you
have like
let's save some model which is like a
thousand dollars time your age plus like
$10,000 times your gender um then it's
like really easy to understand why that
model like might or might not be working
um and then use earners have things like
decision trees and if you have like a
little decision tree um it's also kind
of obvious why this is isn't working
right so if this is a decision tree
about like who died on the Titanic so
it's like if it's a woman they survived
if it's a man and they're more than ten
they died so it's like very simplistic
but it's very easy to understand why it
might not work um because it's very
simple um but then what happens in real
life um is you end up with like much
more complicated decision trees right so
this is a decision tree I made um this
is also much more simple than most of
the things that I've worked with and
it's intentionally like impossible to
understand um but but then the reason
that this is actually tractable so for a
long time I think for like a year i
believe that it was like impossible to
look at huge decision trees and then I
it turned out that I was totally wrong
because if you took out take a look an
individual instance so like you have
like one thing that you put through a
decision tree it only makes like 12
decisions along the way or something
probably um or like maybe 20 like it
makes like a finite amount of decisions
along the way um so I basically thought
that this would be helpful and that it
wouldn't work and then the product
manager on my team who's like the best
built this like being in JavaScript
which like takes the random forest and
like shows you all the decisions I made
and like explains to you exactly what
happened I'm without like really without
even trying to do anything clever it's
just like here's what happened here's
why this thing like why the I'll go to
make this decision and then I started
using it I was like this is the most
useful thing in the world like now I can
see exactly what happened all the time
how did I not have this before like and
it's something that you can build from
scratch like really easily like because
random for us really simple um and like
linear models are really simple and a
lot of like machine learning stuff is
stuff that like you can just like
understand almost everything about how
it works with like relatively little
effort let's not sure about neural
networks but it is true about things
like decision trees right um is like how
they work is super simple um
so oh yeah the other really fun thing
you can do um is make two models so
often you'll you might start it and
you'll make like a really complicated
model um and someone told me that his
favorite things to do is take the
complicated model and look at what it's
outfits are and then like model the
complicated model with a different
simple model which might look more like
this right and then like you still don't
understand exactly what the complicated
model did but you have like a better
sense for what's going on on maybe he's
little more let's look explain your
complicated model and I think this is
like a surprisingly powerful tactic um
my last like super favorite thing to do
is to talk to academics who works in
academia like who's like a PhD student
you're the best I love you academics are
amazing um beauty shouldn't SAR like
also my favorite I went to nips which is
like academic machine learning
conference um and I like spent a lot of
time running granite asking Fiji's to
quit students like explain stuff to me
I'm cuz they're all like really smart
and they know so much and they were like
largely willing to talk to me and they
were like oh wow um you think I know
stuff and I was like that's cuz you're
amazing you know everything um and I got
them to expand like recurrent neural
networks to me and it was wonderful um
yeah um so academics are my favorite uh
reading papers is look very occasionally
my favorite mostly if someone hands them
to me um so yeah oh and I want to talk a
little bit has simple systems are like
the best who likes building like really
simple models that's like all of you I
don't even need to tell you anything um
like linear I have a linear model that
it works in at work um and I can't tell
you how much money it saved the company
but it was a lot it was like a lot of
money and it was wonderful like linear
models are like the best thing in the
world um and I like totally didn't
believe that they would work when I was
a math student and I was dumb cuz I was
like it's like a world debt the world
definitely doesn't behave a linear model
that's stupid and then I like started
actually using them and I was like oh
linear model isn't stupid I'm stupid
they're like the best thing in the world
yeah so
uh that's it now you know how to check
in your network and maybe you're excited
about breaking machine learning models
and using like breaking them to
understand them I am going to let you go
and like away um but you can ask me an
unlimited number of questions in real
life and also on Twitter um thanks for
listening